a new episode of 60 minutes plus takes
us inside a hot new craze for digital
art and other collectibles and you're
going to want to talk about it the u.s
artist known as beeple made history this
year when he sold his purely
digital artwork for more than 69
million dollars the piece called every
day's the first 5 000 days was sold as
an
nft that is a unique computer code that
provides a digital certificate of
authenticity
60 minutes plus correspondent lori
siegel spoke to the hip-hop artist flo
ryda who created his own
nft about his hopes to cash in
let's call it a trend on this trend how
much do you think people are going to
pay for your
your nft how much are you hoping for
billions on top of billions
billions i mean you never know i mean i
have fans that love me across the world
this new advance isn't just for world
famous rappers
it's a technology that could be used to
turn anything
and anyone into an nft up for auction
including me action i'm lori siegel and
i'm about to be turned into a 3d avatar
that's you basically flattened out
that's crazy and then this would be the
wire frame so this is
obviously that happens they wrap this
around you
wow and that's how it works you are
basically
a series of triangles and as you can see
your face is
really a number trying so that's where
the full details at
we wondered just because we can make an
nft of anyone or anything
will anybody actually want it i say this
in a humbling way why would someone want
to purchase
my nft i mean what is the value just
explain it
to me well think of nfts again as
memorabilia
you are now enabling everyone to create
moments and the market will determine
what those moments are valued at perhaps
you can create
a jpeg of yourself in the middle of one
of the best interviews
made history and that that nft will have
a value somebody might be interested
weeks later my 3d avatar now lives in a
virtual space
i'm lori siegel and i'm about to be
turned into a 3d avatar
and then i'm going to be turned into an
nft
welcome to the future of the internet
lori siegel who is also the founder of
dot dot dot media joins us now
uh lori uh the pulitzer prize-winning
art critic jerry saltz of new york
magazine called the whole nft craze and
this is a technical art term
uh crapola uh and this is what's so cool
don't get it too this is what's so
confusing about it it's digital art so
you can make
infinite copies of it and it all looks
the same but only one person is the
quote owner with the nft
right why are people paying so much
money for this stuff sure but and let me
just say
remember when banksy came around a lot
of people just thought the graffiti was
vandalism now people pay millions for it
so it's a physical thing
but that is not in in defense of
anything i just i just need to explain
it
um you know look it's this idea that we
own things we value things in the
physical world right
but in the future we'll spend more time
in digital worlds our children are
already doing this if you have kids and
they're on roadblocks and fortnight
we're now going to value things in the
digital world and this is a way that you
can do that right jack dorsey is selling
his tweet
his first tweet that's i remember this
it says i'm setting up my twitter for
um three million dollars it's kind of
this digital authenticity so like
the the deed to it if you think about
this but everybody has access to it in
the digital world
so it's essentially like bragging rights
of some sort
right well you i mean when you were
asking the question about what is it i
saw a certain quality of desperation and
confusion which i is what i feel
sure do you do you see the value yeah
look like i
you see that i love that you picked that
up i've covered technology for over a
decade and i'm still
trying to wrap my head around it thank
you that makes me feel better
you're not alone but i will say i think
there's a lot of value here and i think
it's super interesting i think it's
interesting if you look at it
in the context of what's coming next in
the internet